l'avait dit votre magazine il est
militant il est engagé a déjà pensé à
vous lancer en politique comme de plus
en plus de personnalités qui viennent de
la télé pour l'instant non mais pourquoi
pas
ce sera niet saracens avec quelques
avait posé la question et je sais je
vais répondre quoi pas la statuaire noël
de se dire tiens c'est dans combien de
temps donc même mois dans un sens il
m'est donc pas longtemps à la fin du
mois ne devrait jamais kemmer non non il
écrit la banque
attendez quoi vous pourriez vous quoi
des élections pourris ou présent kalou
c'est une chose que toi en picardie
après quoi la présidence mais pourquoi
pas bonne on n'a pas dit notre dernier
mot non moi je moi j'irais pas chérie
jamais moi ben non moi non plus loin un
mec comme ça non je rigole je rigole
parce que tout la politique c'est
vraiment un métier c'est un pareil
président lac luxe et des
responsabilités qui sont tellement
énormes que tous les rigolos qui vont je
trouve ça pas bien du tout mais cette
année ces fausses voilà c'est vrai je ne
peux pas avoir un franchement imprévu au
niveau régional jean-pierre au niveau
régional ou national voit pas dsk jean
pierre vous pourriez soutenir
ouvertement quelqu'un avant les
élections là non parce que je suis
journaliste donc je soutiens personne et
des gens que j'aime bien
il ya des gens
qui aiment bien ouais oui les hommes des
femmes ja on t'as demandé les deux c'est
ça la prochaine c'est sûr qu'elle a
atteint problème ah ouais mais comme
tout le monde tout le monde a des
problèmes
la politique c'est quelque chose qui est
quand on voit en ce moment les
difficultés qui se sont abattues sur la
france depuis quelques années depuis les
gilet jaune
la crise du coc vide et cetera rolala je
veux pas ça alors plus sage et moi je
demanderai jamais pour qui tu es tu as
beau dire c'est énorme mais ce que tu as
dit geneviève pour qui tu vas voter ou
pas du tout encore non je me pas du tout
à tomber sabrina fini moi je suis devant
il ya des tas de gens que j'aime bien
j'admire en général les hommes
politiques qui sont des gens quelles que
soient leurs opinions quel que soit leur
bord de l'extrême gauche à l'extrême
droite sur des gens qui se donnent à
fond vous les voyez dans un meeting au
fin fond de la france à 23 heures le
matin à 6 heures ils sont chez bourdin
ils se sont engueulés
attend un courage extraordinaire tout ça
voilà ils ont un idéal et s'attaque
titiller un moment parce que je suis sûr
qu'à peintures de jean pierre attendent
nombreux héritages et candidat à une
élection municipale sur une liste à
amiens en 1983-84 je sais plus il y
avait des municipales à une place non
éligible comme ça je n'espère rien et
donc voilà tout mais vous avez été
draguée par des partis politiques en
revanche à oui bah oui oui vous avez été
draguée par beaucoup de partis
politiques
quelques uns mais quand même partout
quelques heures et non pas partout mais
va partout par dire que la série va dire
que les éoliennes ne servent à résidence
yannick jadot il a pas dû aux apprenants
non mais pourtant je comprends pas parce
que l'écologie c'est que chris a parlé
rillieux un mois ci nous dicte les
éoliennes c'est dangereux c'est parce qu
en allemagne ils ont arrêté le nucléaire
pour mettre des éoliennes comme ça
fonctionne quinze jours que sur trois il
ya de plus en plus de centrales
thermiques en allemagne il peut lui
maintenant de neuf fois plus que la
france applique aux légistes allemands
qui ont décidé ça et je voudrais pas que
les écologistes français fassent la même
connerie pour mais aussi